une nouvelle étude dans la revue
médicale d'hollande cette offre un
portrait assez sombre de l'état de santé
de l'ensemble de l'humanité
cette gigantesque méta analyse affirme
que 95% la population de la planète
souffrent de problèmes de santé et que
le tiers vit avec au moins cinq maladies
et selon les auteurs de cette étude nous
avons donc augmenter considérablement
l'espérance de vie au cours du 20e
siècle mais au détriment des années de
vie vécue en santé mont saint michel
bonsoir c'est un constat qui n'est pas
très réjouissant quand même nom mais je
crois que c'est important de faire le
point c'est notre dernière chronique de
la saison brille ça s'appelle le fardeau
global de la maladie une organisation
2000 chercheurs dans 100 pays
ils ont regardé un peu plus de 300
maladie dans 188 pays
est ce qu'ils voulaient savoir ce qui
était malade qui ne l'étaient pas et
combien de temps ce qu'on reste ensemble
alors regardons les concurrents
conclusion alors déjà on sait que
seulement 80 que 3% de la population
vient senti ça veut dire céline sans
maladie élastique c'est pas beaucoup et
33% le tiers de l'humanité vit avec cinq
maladies ou plus ça c'est 2,3 milliards
de personnes céline c'est beaucoup alors
dites-nous de quelle maladie on parle
ici alors j'ai été surpris moi même de
constater que c'était parce que je
pensais la moitié de toutes les maladies
c'est ça ce sont les modos les maux de
cou la retraite pour le pour le corps
pour l'esprit de la dépression d'anxiété
l'abus d'alcool et l'abus de drogue ça
c'est plus de la moitié du fardeau des
maladies de la planète et est ce qu'on
l'a vu des changements au fil des ans
parce que l'étude devra de 1990 à 2013
oui alors sera peu près un quart de
siècle on a vu que le nombre d'années
que l'on passe en santé diminue de plus
en plus et que les maladies chroniques
graves sont en hausse alors quelle leçon
faut tirer tout ça si on regarde un peu
simplement dans les pays riches
occidentaux ça va pas très bien des
enfants de 0 à 4 ans il n'a que 36 % nos
enfants qui sont sans maladie et pour
les plus de 80 mais là on se rend compte
que c'est 0,3 sont aussi attendait quand
même pu rendre à 80 alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec ce bilan
ben c'est qu'on a un système de santé
qui s'est beaucoup concentrés sur la
longe
évitez à tout prix ce que les gens
disent dans l'étude et bien concentrons
nous maintenant sur la qualité de vie et
sur comment on peut par la prévention
par la nutrition par les sports on en a
parlé tous l'année améliorer l'état de
santé de notre population pour éviter
les maladies chroniques qui nous enlève
des années de santé c'est du bon conseil
laisse pas toujours facile à faire
non non c'est très difficile mais milieu
du travail de plus en plus difficile
parce qu'on est toujours assis on ne
fait pas d'exercice d'y être de plus en
plus difficiles dans le monde occidental
il mènera les pieds en émergeant sur
thoune et pied en émergence
donc il faut revoir les façons
d'améliorer le système de santé par la
prévention et de se reconcentrer sur la
santé et non pas sur la longévité et la
i la survie à tout prix alors michel
merci beaucoup je n'étais en soit aussi
à la rentrée merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup au revoir